so everything that has to do with a
refrigeration and air conditioning is
done by Vapor compression technology
where this chemical refrigerant called
hydrofluorocarbon it absorbs and
releases latent heat except the problem
is that a hydro fluorocarbon it's
contributing significantly to the global
warming problem
and that's why we started thinking that
we can make cooling devices by
stretching nickel titanium wire so we
stretch it and it actually release heat
and you unstretch it's cooling its
surrounding
but it hadn't been a prevalent
phenomenon that was well known so when
we first approached Department of energy
they said as far as we know no such
phenomenon exists
and so that's when we said exactly you
should let us try it
my name is Ichiro Takeuchi I study
Material Science and Engineering at the
University of Maryland
we try to discover a new functional
materials and we also try to come up
with new applications for them
this material this shape memory aloe
especially nickel titanium you know
never stop surprising us shape memory
Alloys have these special properties so
by stretching it it's essentially going
from one crystalline structure to
another and in doing so it necessarily
has to give off heat associated with the
transformation but in turn when you
change the the temperature of the
surrounding of the alloy it goes back to
the original shape and the structure at
the atomic level and it has to absorb
heat and when the material absorbs heat
it's cooling its surrounding except
sometimes atoms could get stuck and then
starts producing defects so the more
Cycles you operate these materials the
more and more defects could pile up and
eventually that's what leads to a
failure so initially 10 12 years ago we
were able to actually make materials
with high temperature and the low
temperature have a compatibility in the
crystal structure sure and we were able
to test that indeed the fatigue life is
long and that's when we discovered that
it could exhibit a really large Cooling
and a heating effect something like 30
degrees Fahrenheit so we started
thinking that we can make cooling
devices out of this and that's sort of
how we got into this field
so we started the project making simple
toy devices we're stretching a strand of
wires together and then we slowly
started moving toward a large scale
devices
ended up taking us 10 years and there's
a lot of really tricky engineering that
went on
it turns out compression doesn't lead to
as much fatigue as in the pension case
so we have a hydraulic actuators that
pushes on the shape memory Outlet which
is held at the other end and that's how
it gets compressed
at the same time we discovered that
cooling air directly is an extremely
inefficient process and that's why now
we use water during every cycle we need
to have water you know have it back and
forth back and forth in the device
but as long as you load it in the right
configuration you know it could survive
more than 10 million Cycles those are
important numbers because if you think
about buying an air conditioner that
immediately translates to tens of
millions of cycle so we designed this
rig in such a way so that we could test
that and at the same time we could
observe large temperature change
and right now we've demonstrated a
cooling device with sufficient power so
that now one can begin to think about
real applications
so there are different directions that
we're pushing this technology as long as
we're working on nickel titanium the
force of the stress is simply too large
and in some instances it requires
Hydraulics and they're pretty
inefficient
if you want to make a viable commercial
product I believe we need to switch to a
different material and it turns out
there are a variety of other shape
memory Alloys so one type is a copper
based shape memory Alloys some of it
requires a lot smaller stress we hope at
that level it's as efficient as a vapor
compression
climate change is real countries are
taking on the challenge but
realistically Vapor compression Will
Survive what we can hope for you know
there will be Niche applications
something like wine fridge perhaps we
could use this for medical Fields where
you know people have to transport organs
and other things cool in a small package
but you know that's a start and whatever
we can do to reduce emission of
hydrofluorocarbons we need to do